today's a special occasion we'd like to
wish all the dads a Happy Father's Day
and it's only fitting to have something
appropriate for this occasion as you
know fathers often play an important
role in anime they may serve as a mentor
be a source of motivation or simply
provide comic relief they can also serve
as that mysterious villain plaguing our
heroes since day one of their journey so
today we're looking at the top 10 most
badass dads and shown in anime ready
[Music]
kick-starting our fathers Day special is
igneel from fairytale hey no one said
all dads have to be humid right
searching foot igneel is one of the
goals of fairytales nuts ooh drag Neil
the fire dragon King wasn't only a
loving father figure to nuts ooh he also
taught the soon-to-be Dragon Slayer all
he could about Dragon Slayer magic
that's why it is such a great mystery as
to why
igneel and the other dragons disappear
on his foster son one mysterious day the
search for igneel is fruitful and he
makes his glorious return when all hope
seems to be lost
igneel uses his magic in the same manner
is Natsu for melee purposes he shoots
out large breaths of fire to damage his
opponent the Battle of the Titans
featuring igneel and acne logia is a
cataclysmic duel
you have to watch very tail for
at number nine we have low death from
soul eater as the leader of the dwma
death the kid's father isn't someone to
mess with while generally a goofball
lord death can be terrifying and
ruthless a remnant of the past that he
discarded before becoming headmaster
he's also one of the few who can stand
toe-to-toe with the almighty Ashura
the powerful villain who happens to be
Lord death other son talk about family
of badasses they fear not though this
isn't the last time you see a badass
father/son combo of Shinigami on a side
note Lord deaths fates different in the
anime and the manga perhaps you'd like
to experience solely to through both
mediums in order to see what's in store
for him
clocking in at number eight is a Cinque
Saki from Bleach it she goes not exactly
the most cheerful of the Shonan
protagonists out there adding to his
grumpiness is his buffoon of a dad ition
then the two are constantly fighting
over the tiniest things at home and you
think that ichigo has his hands full
beyond the happy and immature facade a
she ins a skilled doctor and a powerful
Shinigami that can stand up to even
Aizen he's also instrumental in helping
make ichigo's stronger in preparation
for the key battles in the series
especially in the manga you have to read
the manga and see the arcs that weren't
adapted for anime to see how big and
important to roll ition plays whether
that's in ichigo's past or his present
as they say looks can be deceiving
Berlin was cool country on a list of
badass anime dads we have a van
Hohenheim from Full Metal Alchemist van
Hoven hyams an immortal Alchemist with a
troubled past the sage of the West one
of the series most prominent characters
and importantly to this list the Elric's
enigmatic father who left home when they
were just little that makes him the
perfect foil to the main villain
ironically named father the to serve as
major forces that shaped the conflict in
for Metal Alchemist the game of chess
between these twos beans centuries in
the making poem doesn't try to justify
his action of leaving home but as soon
as we see the end result we're certain
his hearts in the right place as soon as
he returns to the story his unique
relationship with both Edward and
Alphonse is something to look forward to
[Music]
and taking the sixth place on this list
is endeavour from my hero academia now
something for a change in the list of
badass dads we had a list of good dads
who were loving kind-hearted or
generally cool partners in crime to
their children endeavor on the other
hand is none of these endeavor can be
described as driven destructively so
he's introduced as the person who'll
stop at nothing in his quest to overtake
all might as the number one hero
realizing the futility he turns to his
son and uses him in his mad continued
[ __ ] to be number one yes endeavor is a
badass but he's the type of father who'd
gladly abuse his family and used them as
a stepping stone in his hunt for
greatness all in all I think what makes
endeavour interesting is this potential
for change in development he may have
all the gifts in the world but unless he
recognizes why he lacks he'll never be
as great as all might when that day
comes watch out world
that's good
at number five we take a look at monkey
dee dragon from one piece ah monkey dee
dragon the leader of the revolutionaries
and the most wanted man in the one-piece
universe you see having a resume like
that has its perks one you're sure to be
one hell of a badass to the point where
smoker makes no attempt to arrest you
and two you're sure to get one hell of a
nickname that strikes fear into the
hearts of many
and the simple reveal of a relation with
you will certainly send shockwaves that
rocks a person's world however being the
son of a badass dad comes with its
drawbacks I mean you don't expect a dad
who's the world's most wanted man to
just go home and spend some relaxing
quality time with the family do you
such is the fact that Luffy doesn't even
know that he has a father at the start
of this series
that doesn't mean Dragon is negligent
though in fact he's already saved his
son a couple of times in the series
already only time will tell what monkey
dee dragons fully capable of
[Music]
okay
fourth on our list is Vegeta now did
anyone see this coming did anyone expect
the ruthless Saiyan Prince the classical
example of a rival an antihero to the
main character to somehow settle down
and start a family but that's exactly
what he did
watching Vegeta and family makes one
wonder what he went through to end up
like that well lots of things however
that doesn't mean that he's gone soft he
still remains one of the most powerful
forces in the Dragon Ball universe and
he'll strike down all who threaten his
family at least unlike Goku he doesn't
have the habit of dying on you kind of
[Music]
place we have amiibos from Gintama
renowned alien Buster and one of the
strongest men in urgant armor universe
amiibos also happens to be the father of
Kagura and Kamui while his relationship
with his son is an ideal the opposite is
true when it comes to his daughter
he's extremely caring and protective
towards her to the point of doing some
questionable things in order to protect
her he's the type of dad who'd even go
to the lengths of breaking up the family
for the greater good
Umi boy's is indeed the kind of person
who does a lot wrong for the right
reasons in my opinion his story arcs on
of the highest points of Gintama giving
a glimpse to a morally complex and torn
father
[Music]
the yellow flash Minato takes number two
on the list apart from the spiky hair
the desire to be Hokage in order to help
everyone and the brimming confidence
Minato has some major differences with
his son Kuno has yellow flash turns out
to be a lot more sensible and is even
hailed as a genius during his days in
addition to being a genius and a snin
Jia Minato is also a very kind father
one that makes the decision to sacrifice
his life in order to seal the ninetails
away inside his son now that's hardly
love right you don't see a lot of anime
dads make that sacrifice not only for a
son but also for an entire village
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
number one most badass anime dad on the
list is none other than Yugi Rohan MA
from Bucky the grappler the strongest
creature on earth the ogre you don't get
these names that being a serious beast
of a man showcasing inconceivable
strength you can say that Yugi rose more
like a natural disaster an unstoppable
force of nature more than he is a man
few can come close to Yugi Rose might
and none can best him in combat his one
goal in life is to get his son barky to
be strong enough to best him in combat
for such a gargantuan task all morals go
out the window
needless to say Yugi Rose an atrocious
father but what he is is an awesome
final villain one that serves as the
summit that his son hopes to reach and
conquer would Bucky be able to overcome
everything or put an end to his father's
reign of terror I wouldn't count on it
jab you got my token at all you got some
irony as you can see being badass comes
in different forms whether they're
physically mentally or emotionally tough
a lot of anime dads are really more than
just cool or goofy side characters
they're integral to the growth of our
characters I hope that they encourage
you to check out their shows too so
which one is your favorite dad give us a
comment below and let me know leave a
like if you enjoyed the video and
subscribe for more anime content until
next time
[Music]
[Music]